on va plus loin ce soir avec bruno
daroux chroniqueur internationale pour
france24 bruno bonsoir et puis on sera
dans quelques instants avec marie roger
biloa du groupe africain et
international qui va nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau dans quelques instants on va
revenir d'abord sur la guerre en ukraine
cela fait un mois et demi que dure ce
conflit alors que moscou a fait de la
conquête totale du donbass son objectif
prioritaire qui avait dit s'attendre à
brève échéance à une importante
offensive dans cette région la ville de
marioupol elle après plus de quarante
jours de siège serait prête à tomber aux
mains des russes les russes qui pourrait
y avoir utilisé des armes chimiques
interdites par les conventions
internationales c'est ce qu'affirme
notamment le régiment azoff retranché la
barre à marioupol les britanniques
proposent de mener une enquête pour y
voir plus clair écoutez tout de suite le
sous secrétaire d'état britannique aux
forces armées
et nous ne savons rien de plus que ce
que vous avez documenté au sujet de
rapports circulant sur les réseaux
sociaux craignent un et faisant état d'
armes chimiques utilisés à marioupol
cependant pour être clair nous avons
travaillé dans l'urgence pour savoir si
des armes chimiques ont été utilisés ou
non si elles ont été et le ministre des
affaires étrangères l'a rappelé les
responsables devront rendre des comptes
le recours aux armes chimiques est
abominable c'est une ligne rouge à ne
pas franchir et toutes les options sont
sur la table pour y apporter une réponse
bruno daroux de quelle option parle ici
les britanniques les britanniques qui
parle simplement de l'option
d'utilisation par les russes d'agents
chimiques d'armes chimiques qui en
principe sont interdites mais on sait
que ça a été utilisé en syrie notamment
ce avait failli provoquer l'intervention
des américains et des français et en
souvient qu'au dernier moment barack
obama avait reculé mais à cette heure il
faut quand même rester prudent on n'a
pas encore de preuves que des armes
chimiques ont été utilisés par l'armée
russe d'ailleurs le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken vient de dire
que selon les renseignements américains
les russes envisagent d'utiliser des
armes chimiques
donc pour le moment pas de preuves des
soupçons et puis on espère surtout que
ce ne sera pas le cas mais clairement vu
la résistance à laquelle doivent faire
face les russes on ne peut pas exclure
malheureusement que un moment donné pour
finaliser cet assaut sur marioupol qui
s'éternise les russes recours aux armes
chimiques comme ils l'ont fait en syrie
notamment oui voilà est telle qu'un
marie roger biloa bonsoir vous nous avez
rejoint sur ce plateau le 25 mars
dernier face à de telles accusations
déjà d'utilisation d'armes chimiques joe
biden le président américain promettait
une réponse de l'otan quelle réponse ça
pourrait être concrètement par livrer
les armes etc ça ça sur le poids sur
lequel il ya un consensus qui se dégage
même si c'était très difficile au départ
on avait peur de cette co belligérance
maintenant on sent que là l'alliance
autant ce libère un peu des contraintes
de vue là la nature des destructions et
aider et voilà des massacres qui sont en
train de se commettre sur nos yeux mais
à part ça c'est quand même dramatique
pour les ukrainiens ont soit espérer
qu'ils vont pas le faire qu'ils vont pas
utiliser l'anc mixer juste de l'espoir
et de la défense de preuve de l'absence
de preuves
c'est le régiment je le disais le
régiment à azov qui combat marioupol qui
a notamment parlé de cas pareil ça mais
on a vu quand même aussi un
officier de l'armée russe qui disait que
si c'était 6 et authentifié que nous
aurons pas le choix d'autres choix que
d'utiliser l'armé chimique pour
minimiser nos pertes en vies humaines et
les faire sortir les les ukrainiens donc
il ya beaucoup de vraisemblance et comme
on le dit de plus en plus que poutine
veut un succès pour mais
voilà il y a il faut absolument terminer
le travail sur marie paule donc tous les
moyens sont bons justement sur le régime
en azote c'est pas n'importe quel régime
en argument qu'on composé de
d'ultranationalistes on va le dire
élégamment
chi chi dont voilà est sujet à caution
dans ses déclarations marioupol
bruno daroux qui devrait tomber dans les
heures peut-être dans les jours qui
viennent
marioupol qui n'est plus qu'un cimetière
90% des maisons ont été rasées il ya des
milliers de morts pourquoi cette prise
de marioupol serait stratégique pour les
russes alors allez stratégique pour
d'horizon en fait d'abord parce que ça
permettrait d'assurer une continuité
territoriale entre les possessions russe
désormais en seconde ça qu'il faut dire
malheureusement
dans le donbass et toute la côte sud de
l'ukraine ça permettrait de faire une
continuité jusqu'à la crimée donc c'est
la seule la crim est annexée en 2014
voilà voilà plus les territoires qui
depuis ont été annexées depuis le 24
février donc ça c'est le premier intérêt
stratégique et puis le deuxième ça
permettrait véritablement de transformer
la la mer d'azov la petite mer d'azov
qui donne par un corridor très étroit
sur la mer noire d'assurer le contrôle
de la mer d'azov par les russes de
privatiser en règle sans cette mer
d'azov qui étaient partagés de manière
plus ou moins
comment dire
plus ou moins équilibrée on va dire
entre les ukrainiens et les russes
depuis 2004 la là ce serait donc la
privation
pour l'ukraine d' un débouché très
important sur cette période le président
russe vladimir poutine a assuré que
l'offensive russe en ukraine se
poursuivent et très calmement on va
l'écouter tout de suite
son objectif est parfaitement clair les
nobles
notre objectif principal est de venir en
aide à la population du dombass
la venir en aide à la population du don
de basse il confirme donc marie roger
biloa l'objectif de l'armée russe
s'emparer du donbass vladimir poutine
qui a estimé aussi aujourd'hui que butch
à était un fake un bout de chasser ce
massacre qu'il ya eu dans la banlieue de
kiev une fausse information selon lui
toute cette rhétorique c'est encore une
fois pour justifier son intervention en
ukraine auprès de la population russe
bien sûr oui bien sûr bon vous savez
c'est la guerre c'est aussi une guerre
de l'information donc
il fait tout ce qu'il peut de son côté
pour
faire accepter le narratif qui l'a servi
aux russes
peut-être qu'ils y croient lui-même pour
également aussi on ne sait jamais plus
tard et éviter les poursuites parce que
tout ça aussi on ne sait pas jusqu'où
les le camp occidental ira dans sa sa
quête de justice vis-à-vis de poutine et
et puis on s'est rendu compte plus c'est
gros plus ça passe ça peut il y à des
vérités parle elle nous voyons chose on
dit c'est pas ça et on joue sur le fait
que la vérité n'est pas
forcément par les deux camps et chacun
est maniée manipule comme il peut mais
surtout les russes bien sûr et donc on
essaie de semer le doute c'est dire
c'est même pas un sujet comme en train
de dire à mes bouts de chasser ils
disent que c'est fait mais ils le disent
mais je crois qu'il ya suffisamment
d'évidences pour reconnaître qu'il y à
un carnage sans nom des crimes de guerre
qui ont été commis bruno daroux et
sèment le doute depuis le début les
russes
dans ce conte fils aime le look c'est à
dire que ba et effectivement ils restent
droits dans leurs bottes sur leur
narratif de dire parfois même contre
l'évidence en fait si on pense par
exemple à bout de chaque en fait ce sont
des soldats ukrainiens qui ont tué des
civils ukrainien pour ensuite faire
accuser l'armée russe de ces exactions
faut rappeler qu'aujourd'hui alors après
le chiffre appartient à cette
personnalité mais le maire de bouchain a
dit qu'on était quand même à 403
cadavres qui avaient été retrouvés dans
les rues de et les décombres deux bouts
de chou est là où il y aura encore ce
cas là c'est mario bros on sait pas
combien il y en a ce sera très difficile
d'accès aujourd'hui et on ne sait pas
combien de gens sont sous les décombres
déjà on parle de milliers de gens me
disaient c'est un véritable carnage
quelqu'un d'y au début de la guerre mais
oui c'est une guerre à bassens en
intensité ce qui est surtout des
destructions de boulimie il y aura à la
fin bien sûr des villes entières
détruites dont je ne sais pas de quelle
manière ils craignent peut gagner cette
guerre c'est la moitié de ce territoire
électrique et s'il y a autant de morts
donc cessez du perdant perdant pour les
deux parties alors ils sont comptés les
les accusations de viol un essai ce
livre vous le dis mais reviennent ce qui
aujourd'hui président et craignant déjà
des centaines de cas de chez nous ça va
sur des mineurs et des jeunes enfants
ouais absolument donc visiblement là ce
sera une des grandes questions
après la guerre mais déjà cette question
se pose de savoir si non mais il ya eu
un feu vert en fait pour toutes ces
unités de faire à peu près ce qu'elle
voulait ou si ce sont des comportements
erratiques liés à la pratique de la
guerre bon la question franchement venir
le pire est à venir ils ont tous selon
la question reste c'est de la
responsabilité du haut du haut
commandement et peut-être même de
vladimir poutine là aussi on va
j'aimerais à présent qu'on parte au mali
le mali ou ou la russie justement
renforce son influence son influence
depuis quelques mois la ministre
allemande des affaires étrangères est
arrivé sur place hier soir elle se
rendra ensuite au niger anna lena
barbeuk qui doisneau à me rencontrer
demain le chef de la junte malienne
évaluer la situation politique et
sécuritaire dans le pays ainsi décider
du maintien ou non de l'armée allemande
la bundeswehr au mali notamment dans le
cadre de la minus ma hier après le
massacre de moura fin mars en tout cas
les 27 pays européens eux ont décidé de
suspendre les formations militaires au
mali écouter le chef de la diplomatie
européenne on en reparle juste après
va quitter la mission d'entraînement les
maisons dans tous les membres militaires
de troupes on être pas tellement aux
arrêtés on va continuer à faire d'eux
des du conseil du conseil de la
formation de dijon des lois de la guerre
marie roger biloa les européens il reste
quand même au sahel avec des activités
de conseil en viens d'entendre josep
borrell malgré la décision des autorités
maliennes de faire appel notamment au
groupe russe wagner c'est quoi c'est une
forme de compromis de la part des
européens c'est à dire les européens
sont dans un dilemme très important
parce que est-ce qu'on quitte le sahel
et on laisse là toute la place à wagner
et à la russie par le ceto dans le
contexte actuel où on maintient une
forme de présence est pour ça que même
la déclaration du ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'europe
joseph bourrel et tandis que nous
partons nous restons bons et il faudra
qu'il clarifie on met en ce qui concerne
la halle à l'allemagne il faut quand
même saluer leur démarche c'est à dire
et à la ministre qui vient pour
s'assurer elle même de ce qui se passe
sur le terrain
en prévision d'une séance parlementaire
qui aura lieu en mai et où la question
de l'engagement allemand au mali va être
débattue on va voter pour contre donc ça
m'a juste fait penser qu'en france les
engagements militaires sont pas
débattues au parlement mais un seul a
dit au mali
c'est clair que on se pose beaucoup de
questions parce que en à une junte
militaire qui
s'est surtout attisé un pseudo
patriotisme alors que et
feignies font face à des sanctions parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas rétablir la
démocratie veulent pas rétablir un
régime civil et à aucun moment ces gens
là ne sont demandés est ce que ça vaut
pas le coup compte se retire ou tout
simplement qu'on donne un chronogramme
correct pour éviter au peuple malien cet
aventurisme avec les les sanctions de la
cedeao et pour la cda aux l'enjeu car
même crucial on est déjà trois coups
d'état on voit comment ces erratique en
guinée et aussi on voit que les
militaires ne sont pas meilleurs que les
civils et de plus en plus et je pense
que un moment donné les maliens vont se
rendre compte que le plus intéressant
pour eux c'est vraiment de pousser cette
junte militaire qui s'est déjà illustrée
aussi à la fois par les actes comme sion
mais surtout par une violence inégalée
au mali jédir il ya eu des bavures de
barkan notamment lorsqu'il ya une frappe
sur un mariage c'est une bavure mais là
on a embarqué des civils et pendant des
jours et des jours une vague déclaration
d'amour à l'amour en mars et tout ça
parce qu'ils veulent montrer qu'ils ont
des résultats qui sont efficaces qu'ils
savent combattre le djihadisme tout seul
mais mais ils sont préparés à rien du
tout c'est absolument dramatique s'il se
passe mal bruno daroux un dernier mot
sur le mali non mais voilà la question
aussi c'est justement le rôle de wagner
puisqu'on connaît un peu les les
méthodes de ce groupe de mercenaires qui
permet en permanence à vladmir poutine
de dire que la russie n'intervient pas
m'enfin en laisse en fait ces supplétifs
faire absolument ce qu'ils veulent mais
le fait même que ce n'est pas une armée
professionnelle que c'est un groupe de
mercenaires laisse libre cours aux
exactions saisi ainsi plus des civils et
ne se soucient plus des civils on veut
des effectivement un résultat à
d'ailleurs wagner présent aussi en
centrafrique présent certainement n'en a
pas la preuve absolue mais en ukraine
également donc voila et la question plus
largement c'est est-ce que via ce groupe
de mercenaires vladimir poutine ne veut
pas prendre une importance réelle
s'implanter d'un point de vue politique
que militaire je dirais dans des pays
comme le mali qui sont fragilisés
politiquement et évidemment dégagé pour
de bon la fluence occidental un dernier
mot juste et clair pour les
téléspectateurs les allemands
réfléchissent à au retrait de leurs
contingents dans la force de l'onu
ministre de la minus la
marque anne la forêt française s'est
retirée takouba la force européenne
et l'amusement n'a pas le droit d'aller
enquêter à amour un amour à on a
vraiment plus le temps merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci bruno tarreau merci
beaucoup marie roger biloa merci à tous
les deux d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau pas ça